so I'm originally from Vancouver Canada
where I studied uh and worked as a civil
engineer I worked on hydrology problems
kind of trying to figure out how or
model how much water would fall into
different places to cover up mine
deposits or to cover up or to power
electrical power plants um
I went to France to do my Masters in
Business and uh a little
Divergence here I like to think about
like all the people that uh also brought
me here today and DJ Patel did a talk
about
um where data science came from this
morning and when I was in business
school there was that Harvard Business
review article that he was talking about
with the sexiest
um
job title in the world or whatever it
was and I also read that article and I
was like I'm going to become a data
scientist
um so I left business school and went to
the U.S uh
where I worked at a speech technology
company and that's where I really got
interested actually in machine learning
um and I then went on to work in data
science and machine learning on uh
problems at Heroku uh and then at GitHub
um GitHub I spent time working on
machine learning infrastructure and came
to understand the importance of uh
resilient infrastructure for production
and critical path applications and also
uh how difficult it is to take something
that you trained a model you trained in
a batch method on historical
observations and put that into real time
I left GitHub to work a little bit on
this problem and ended up working on
bite wax founded this company that also
has the same name for the open source
project and I'm the CEO there now and
it's a staple python State full stream
processor and it came out of this idea
of like how can we make it easier to
take
um
whatever you did to data in a in a batch
process for training your model and put
it in real time and it kind of evolved
from that uh into something a bit a
little bit more generally applicable
anyway when I'm not working on bite wax
um
I like to stop in here my daughter she's
10 and a half months old and she's like
the cutest thing ever her name's ziya so
I'm working on learning how to be a dad
which don't ever do that at the same
time as you start a company it's
exhausting
um so anyway let's go into getting real
time
um oh uh this was supposed to be a
joke
um and the joke was that I'm now going
to explain to you
um you know how do you make what is real
time how do you make real time happen
and there's like a airflow uh file there
for uh uh to schedule a job and then you
just change the schedule interval from
like 15 uh minutes or five hours or
whatever down to like
0.0001 seconds and then you just see
what happens and it blows up
um but obviously this was too big or
something I don't really know but the
point uh I'm trying to make is that it's
uh it's an area or a topic that we don't
have a lot of consensus on in the
industry
like if you talk to someone today about
uh whether or not you need uh or more
traditional analytical tools like a data
warehouse or a bi layer or metrics and
why we need metrics Etc there's like
quite a wide and Broad consensus on why
we need those tools what they are what
they mean with as far as real-time data
processing and the technologies that
power that I don't think we have the
same understanding and consensus so
um today what I want to do is talk about
this topic uh real-time data processing
and I hope that at the end of this
you'll have a little bit more
understanding of why one would use
real-time processing within the
organization the different types of uh
workloads that could be real time and
then talk about two case studies from my
time at GitHub that relate to this and
then a little bit about architecture
but before we do that
I'll just get some definitions out of
the way
everyone's in the streaming track right
now so they probably already know what
these all mean but it's the level set so
what is Real Time real time is defined
uh as anything that is perceived to
happen in real time by human which is an
extremely fuzzy definition but
quantitatively what that uh means it's
anything that happens in the sub-second
realm
um uh and real time can actually be uh
um so or a real-time data processing can
actually happen in both a batch and a
stream processing fashion stream
processing just refers to processing one
uh datum at a time that's flowing in a
continuous stream and bad processing as
you probably all know is when you gather
a batch of data and process it all at
once so when you get the batch smaller
and smaller and smaller you can get
closer to real time and that's what
spark structured streaming does with
micro uh batches
so we've gotten all that out of the way
now we can move into what we actually
wanted to talk about which is real time
processing and the different types of
real-time workloads and uh so on and so
forth
so this is the first self-driving car Mr
Bean was like really ahead of his time
no this is um what I want to talk about
here is that in our day-to-day lives for
helping us all understand uh real time
and why we need it in our day-to-day
lives we're receiving like
so much so many inputs like hundreds and
hundreds of inputs and we're reacting to
those in real time and one good example
of this is driving a car when you're
driving a car or maybe playing a sport
when you're driving a car like playing a
sport you have a lot of inputs and your
body is your brain is like you know
analyzing what's going on you're
reacting to it in real time
um and so you could imagine if we were
to like make an analogy here to doing
that in a batch or less real-time Manner
and you would like wait for a duration
of time and all these inputs of all the
systems going on around you take all
that information and then try to like
forecast out what to do for the next
like 15 seconds it would be a complete
disaster and you'd probably crash in
your favorite sport would be uh
horrendous to play or watch so that was
just to kind of level set where we are
in with respect to real-time processing
and
we could draw some conclusions here is
that uh in the instance of driving a car
we're kind of making like a life or
death decision and so maybe we need
real-time processing for stuff like that
or in the context of playing a sport
it's a elevated user experience and so
maybe in the case when there's a
potentially elevated user experience we
want to move to real-time processing but
that's
not very concrete and doesn't really
help scale out our thinking around that
so I'd like to think about the two types
of use cases as analytical and
operational uh workloads sorry not use
cases
um
analytical use cases
analytical workloads sorry are workloads
that require low latency
freshness
and also the capability of retrieval
um
so the
most obvious you know it has to be
something that is queryable and the most
obvious example that probably most of
you have interacted with
on LinkedIn you get a notification if
your profile has been viewed when you
click into that like profile view
notification you're taken to a
something that looks like that I had 605
profile views so I'm you know it's
trending up but anyway you can see the
historical data all the way up to the
most fresh the freshest data should I
say so we have uh this idea of freshness
and we're also able to query that data
we're able to filter it and change it
and so we're able to
um retrieve different dimensions of that
data let's say so that's an example of a
real-time analytical
workload another example I have here is
this super fuzzy uh picture is a
instacart
order so when you order from instacart
and then you're you go into your your
order and you can see the updated
ETA
and so this is another example of an
analytical
real-time workload on the other hand
operational workloads as I've bucketed
them for the purposes of this talk you
have low latency
you also have fresh freshness but then
you have this idea of it being reactive
and so the idea there is that some of
the business logic or some of the
decision making is actually embedded in
inline
in whatever is supporting it so if it's
a streaming use case it's inside the
streaming processor so there's a there's
something happening to that data in a
decision being made in in line there so
one uh
good example of this is
um
fraud detection what you can see here is
like a little text message uh thing so
the fraud detection system I think this
was like a
Chase Chase Bank fraud detection system
is
um
basically taking all the inputs in real
time and then making a decision about
them uh without the kind of human in the
loop and then it makes the decision on
what to do and and then it talks to this
human and says hey I tag this is fraud
like say yes or no
um
another example of this is in the
financial markets
uh high frequency trading or some other
types of trading uh you're having you
have all these Market signals happen
happening and then the
um the program the software program is
making a decision uh whether or not to
buy or sell and they're kind of
competing on how fast they can they can
make that decision
um
so one more thing I wanted to touch on
here uh with this
brilliant illustration from stable
diffusion uh is this idea of
um the human in the loop versus the
machine in the loop so if you look at
different examples across analytical and
then at across operational uh workloads
there's this idea of like the human uh
kind of being in the loop uh or being
more involved in the analytical and less
involved if or or not involved in the
operational and I think this is uh best
um
the best example of this is coming back
to the high frequency trading uh about I
think it was like just over 10 years or
about 10 years ago there was a TED Talk
uh that I saw that piqued my interest by
a man named Sean Gurley and he talked
about this in the the world of
algorithms I guess is what it was titled
and uh he talks about in the financial
markets
when they started developing
um systems that could trade without
human interference or whatever humans in
the loop they started to witness that
there were these these machines were
like trading with each other and so the
machines could react to input various
different inputs or input sources and to
each other before a human could even
understand what was going on and he like
you know draws all this um future and
expands on this uh this world of the
machines and how we're like the humans
living in it
all of this is is really to summarize
how uh in the analytical use case so if
you find yourself uh with something in
your business where you think there's
value to be derived and there's a human
in the loop there's probably a subset of
tools within the real-time space that
fall under this analytical
um uh analytic analytical workload and
if you're building algorithmic trading
system or something where you believe
that there's no actually not a
requirement for the human in the loop
um you're more likely to fall under this
operational
um
category
okay so we talked about the two
different types of real-time uh
workloads uh next thing I want to do is
get a little bit more concrete with a
couple of
um
case studies of uh decisions we made at
GitHub for some of the products that you
may or may not have used before
so the team I was a part of uh was
responsible for a few data products that
ended up on github.com
two of these were these two lists one is
the trending repositories and the other
is the trending Developers
um and they're on the GitHub Explorer
page
if you
um
have ever seen it before
anyway uh so the the training
repositories and trending developers
were
basically we took a series of actions
that had happened to these different
repositories and we would try to
determine which ones were trending or
not so you have like stars Forks views
and stuff like that all of this data was
available in a service that another team
managed that was a uh that was um
uh streaming platform it was all
available in Kafka and we did have the
capacity to write it uh to make it so
that we could have like a real-time
trending product
um but we ultimately made the decision
not to uh run it as a real-time product
and the reason that we did that
was first and foremost our team was
largely
data scientists and machine learning
Engineers who had never worked with uh
streaming platforms or stream processors
and the other thing that's probably more
important
is that this was a net new product so uh
in like 2017 or 2018 is when this was
shipped and we had no clue on the impact
what the impact of the Explorer page
would be and if it actually was going to
provide value to the users of
um GitHub and if it would be sticky so
like if it would make them return back
to the platform and get increasingly
more value
um from the platform if we move that to
real time so we kind of stayed in our
lanes with what we knew
and we made the decision to uh do this
as a batch workload
um off of our uh you know running some
queries against Presto where the real
the data landed from Kafka uh do it at
nightly and then we put it in a mySQL
database and it could be retrieved from
github.com
um
so this uh in fact was not a real-time
uh workload but could have been and if
it was it would be a great example of a
analytical use case uh in the instance
in which people uh wanted to interact
with this data in real time so you could
think about
uh how it might be interesting if you're
a venture capitalist sitting in this
field that you want to look at all the
companies that have like trending stars
and you want to kind of dive into that
data so if you wanted to be able to do
that it would be a great analytical uh
use case where the customer as a human
is interacting with that data and they
want the freshest and most real-time
data
so the other uh
thing that we worked on
with star spam and so this is a a chart
from a recent blog post from I think it
was like dagster I don't know maybe
there's someone from Dexter here I don't
think so but anyway uh they were looking
at clearly what is a fail of uh GitHub
to detect star spam but um that's not
the real reason uh I want to talk about
star spam so GitHub in some from from
one perspective is essentially like a
multi-sided marketplace where you're
matching developers to open source
projects
if you sort of squinted it that's uh
what you could see and a very important
metric
um that many of us use is uh Stars we
use it as a proxy for the utility of the
project or maybe the health of the
project and the community behind it
um and so
if we were to not catch star spammers uh
there would be a degradation of the
value of the platform
for at least one side of the marketplace
they would eventually leave and you'd
have this sort of downward spiral of the
overall value of the GitHub platform for
the users and the open source projects
um at GitHub we decided to
um
we we decided to use uh Flink and uh we
have the data available in Kafka so we
could
in some way shape or form Shadow band
some of these users so
um I don't know what's really going on
today this was like two years ago
so this is a perfect example of
operational processing
um
where a decision was made to Shadow ban
a user based on a set of rules that we
had outlined in code so it was kind of
auditable and then that user would be
um submit to for human review
and then they could determine whether or
not it was made erroneously or or not
um
well we're here on the subject of stars
I work on bite wax so if you want to
take a moment at some point in the near
future and go to bitewax slash bite wax
on GitHub and give me a star that'd be
great
um
uh uh yeah so anyway
um what I want to touch on next is like
uh we did this like quasi-real time
um
but I wanted to touch on just sort of
the value of uh making a decision in
real time and how the latency is related
to potentially to the return on
investment of a project and that's when
you should make a decision to move it to
real time so in this instance
um or in both these instances we can
sort of
talk about
um
the value of moving these either of
these to real time so uh trending was
related to stars because we use stars as
part of the
um
uh input for determining whether or not
a project should be trending or not
um and so in the instance in which we
had to if we had decided to make
trending a real-time uh product it would
be even more necessary to maintain the
value of the platform by doing this in
in as close to as real time as possible
because
part of the I kind of want to be able to
stand over here part of the reason why
we uh promote projects they get more
stars so if we had a lot of star spam
and then you would end up on the
training page you would have this sort
of like uh spiral and this like gaming
effect where you would have a really
negative uh response going on
um and this is going to lead me into
this concept of uh the value of a
project
um
versus the latency
so if you're to speak with or if you
were at earlier talks I don't know
someone probably mentioned this today in
the streaming track that the value of
data degrades over time and they always
say that it looks something like the uh
the function that you see on the left
but I think that the reality is is that
it does degrade over time
but most projects or most uh data
generally fall in the category of the
s-curve on the right where at some point
the return or the value of that data
kind of caps out with respect to latency
so as you move closer and closer and
when we look back at what we were just
talking about with those two case
studies
um
the trending project or the trending in
the uh
the trending repos and trending
developers there was actually only a
fraction of the total traffic for
github.com actually landed on that page
and it was in we couldn't uh
um attribute that there was a lot of
value generated from that product and so
moving it to real time wouldn't have
really had a a higher return on
investment and so in this instance both
of these ended up falling into this sort
of curve where because the trending
product actually didn't increase in
return on investment exponentially as we
moved latency closer to zero
uh we didn't have to look out for Star
spammers uh in a millisecond type of
time frame and it was easy enough to
catch them on the hours time frame
instead and so if we could like put
hours here like you know the value
degraded to a certain point and then it
just sort of uh capped out
okay
um
we've talked about the uh relationship
of the return on investment of a project
with respect to latency we've talked
about the different real-time workloads
and I want to jump into a couple
architecture slides many of you will
probably already be familiar with these
um these two architectures that I'm
going to outline and uh that's fine I'm
just going to give my opinion on some of
this uh
well you have here is the Lambda
architecture Lambda architecture was
coined like by Nathan Mars I think
something like 12 years ago
as a way to beat the cap theorem
essentially what it is is you have uh
two um
separate processes going on one in batch
one in streaming uh one in a stream
process and the batch process is kind of
working at some time frame like an hour
or four hour or five hour or whatever
and it's going to be determined to be
consistent and then you can have a batch
view on that and then the real time is
doing its best job to kind of fill in
the gaps so then your application can
query
a near real time
uh data set between those two uh what
you can probably guess is this is very
complicated to manage uh because your
application has to do a lot of work to
make sure it's querying from the right
places and and merging that data
appropriately and then you also have to
manage two code bases
across your project essentially to code
bases
um
one of the pros and one thing that's
kind of interesting is like most
organizations just kind of like end up
here like or end up being here and like
never get to that but anyway most
organizations start with like a batch
processing approach because it's like
readily available
um you you maybe don't know any
real-time use cases where you're
actually going to get a lot of value and
it just makes sense and organizations
grow organically and if you took uh if
you squinted the Lambda architecture you
could see a world in which you can uh as
required you can add a
um a street when a stream use case
streaming use case requires it you could
add this additional layer and you could
kind of grow organically from your batch
system
uh shortly after Lambda architecture was
coined um Jay crap uh
according to the Kappa architecture and
you can see that it's like a lot more
straightforward but it relies on the
systems to take on a large burden of of
what was done in that uh more difficult
to maintain system so the like instantly
you can see the application has a lot
less burden it's just going to retrieve
the data as required but then at the
same time your stream processing system
your streaming platform have a lot more
burden on them the streaming platform
has to be your record of Truth it has to
be durable and replayable and the stream
processor has to be able to mainstate
has to be able to track progress and all
this sort of stuff and so it's quite
complicated and what we got out of that
was Kafka and Flink which are both
amazing pieces of software but they're
also very complex and very hard to
maintain
um one thing that I believe is missing
from the Kappa architecture and this is
because of my view as a data scientist
is that uh first it's very expensive to
maintain data in the streaming platform
and so normally you end up with some
window of time that you keep it around a
retention period like 30 days or
whatever
and so you can't query historical data
as easily but on that subject of
querying historic data it's very hard to
ad hoc explore the data that's available
in this system
stream processors are extremely powerful
but you generally need to know what you
need to do and you need to know what you
want out of the system so you can write
the code and then it can run whereas
most of the time when I'm writing code
as a data scientist I'm sort of doing it
in an exploratory way in an ad hoc
fashion trying to understand and get
meaning from my data
um so it would be nice if I could do
that
you probably have also heard of like a
couple other architectures data mesh and
data Fabric or Delta
um the Delta architecture which is like
databricks one
um I'm not going to talk about those I
haven't seen a lot of that usage yet the
usage of those architectures yet so
they're they're still evolving but
there's I believe some Merit
uh okay so we've now
um
I've now presented my view of what
real-time processing is the different
types of workloads
um and try to create sort of a framework
for understanding of when you should uh
adopt real time and why
um and now I'm going to talk about the
Technologies uh and companies that are
working in the space just briefly
um so you you know what to look for and
how to identify when you should use uh
the different Technologies
um
so it kind of looks like this this isn't
uh this is these aren't all the
companies but these are a lot of the
companies and there's a lot here right
when you look at this you're like holy
that's super overwhelming and all
of these companies in some way shape or
form send a message like we're the
real-time processing platform or where
they're streaming platform and so it's
very difficult to understand what's
going on
um and there's like a lot more that I
probably didn't include here so we could
draw some lines
and we could put these into different
groups so we have like capture and
ingest and we could have streaming
storage slash transport layer and then
the operational and the analytical
processing I was talking about before
um there's some of these fit into
multiple boxes so it's it's not perfect
but I did my best to put uh technology
where it could be used
um uh so I might be wrong right uh and
this is also still like very
overwhelming
um so we could look at it one piece at a
time these are just three things uh snow
plow is probably the most common
behavioral
data platform for capture and ingest
division maybe is the most popular CDC
technology for for uh capturing it into
um
a storage platform Buzz is a a new tool
from uh that is just very simple to
validate and capture data
um
uh the industry has sort of in some
respect adopted Kafka API almost as like
the protocol so all three of these uh
our Kafka API compatible and they are
transport layers that we see people
using and that we use
you know when we're building out demos
with bite wax or or guides Etc on how to
build streaming systems
um or real-time systems
you have operational processing layer
where the best obviously the best
project is by Wax no I'm just I'm just
kidding
um the most widely adopted project is
Flink and it's been around for like over
10 years or at least 10 years
um so it's extremely powerful software
uh spark structured streaming which I
mentioned at the very beginning is
another tool for doing some of this
operational processing
um and is widely widely used although
it's generally what I hear is that it's
more often used in the streaming world
when it's a a you have a very serious
big problem that you're tackling and you
can invest a significant amount of
resources to manage it
um
yeah analytical processing I put the
streaming databases here and even though
the streaming database is probably uh
sit across both operational processing
and analytical processing and that's why
people are excited about them
uh
and if you uh were here earlier you
would have heard Frank talk about
materialize and so you already know what
a streaming database is otherwise
there's three olap um real-time olap uh
Solutions there clickhouse Pinot Drew
which are I see as the most common
tiny birds on clickhouse Star trees
Pinot Drew just imply I think
um the idea behind a real-time olap
database uh seems to be
um something that you're like I don't
know really when I need that or why I
need that
um it's like I outlined in the
analytical processing it's when it needs
to be queryable uh it has to have the
freshest data and you need to be able to
query it at low latency
and so that's when those generally uh
fit in the one difficult thing about a
real-time olap database is
um
they kind of fall apart with the concept
of joins because you can't joins are
expensive as we all know
um and so you need to do a lot of your
processing before it gets into the
real-time olap database so that your
query is actually
um happens within a reasonable amount of
time and so you generally end up with a
pipeline that looks like
Kafka or whatever to Flink to do some
more some joints and some processing and
then over to Pinot or click house
and once again that's where maybe the
streaming databases can simplify this
entire experience in fact I think it's
some at some point in time materialize
will probably do three of these or maybe
they already do or or all of them but
uh we'll see how things turn out
um okay so you might have thought that
was it but I have uh one more thing
um
it's the Zai architecture no I just put
her in here because she always gives me
Applause regardless of how good my
presentation is no I this was like a
little thought process of a
um something that I'll put a GitHub
repository up about at some point
um from my perspective uh coming from
machine learning and data science
background this is an architecture
um that I would use uh frequently and I
use frequently in my guides and demos uh
trying to explain to people when you
would use something like this so uh I
select red panda
often as a streaming platform because
it's a lot easier for me to manage and
it's a single binary but it's still
Kafka compatible so I can use the same
API by wax for the um stream processor
and then I said Downstream system
depending on what I want to do I can
write that data out to S3 or over to
redis and then my application can have
access to the data redis could be subbed
in you could have something like
Cassandra or you could have the
real-time olap database there
um
and then if I dump data into S3 I don't
know if anyone here has ever heard of
this thing called duck DB but uh
I've heard it a couple times at this
conference so maybe people have
yeah it's an easy way to query that data
because you could write it on a bike
into parquet files and then query those
in a performant manner
so I'll leave you all with that
um
once again it's bite wax
b-y-t-e-w-a-x github.com
if you want to check it out
um
yeah thank you for all for listening
foreign